[Applaudissements]
lui aussi est ce qui vous le stress au
quotidien qu'est ce que vous faites pour
déstresser
parions pour eric naulleau qui si vous
stresse de passer d'une émission à
l'autre constamment pacéré d'or de quoi
j'me mêle btp était pleine ah ouais t'as
un problème c'est que nous sommes à
l'autre la télé ça vous stresse les
émissions tout ça non c'est la
préparation une fois que c'est là où
elle a préparé aussi que vous avez pas
de lyon non mais touche mon passé six
heures ces six joueurs préparation au
minimum à parler vraiment vous préparez
de cause mais un peu quand même
maintenant tu peux maintenant je préfère
ne pas parler en dehors de la présence
de mon avocat
non mais ça en combien de temps vous
travaillez pour de quoi j'me mêle d'une
heure pour préparer sa voie la plus
difficile balance son poste c'est plus
long vous travaillez boileau se pose
comme un temps à bas peut alors au moins
le double [ __ ] plus que présentateur
deux heures pour valence ton post est
une honte c'est un quadra bravo non
voilà maintenant c'est pour ça que les
success voilà la recette du bonheur mais
il bosse lis beaucoup plus ça non à bâle
au minimum 1 tm 4a de préparation mais
les people c'est 8 heures à peu près tu
mens pour moi la préparation de ces le
respect des téléspectateurs il n'y a
qu'à le détecteur de mensonges ou
stressés pourquoi bénéfique pareil moi
c'est beau c'est pour le boulot c'est
non mais vraiment je veux je veux je
veux que vous soyez content qu'on
m'appelait le matin en me disant si je
compte en ligne alors que je la prenne
tous les jours prêt à donner ces
chiffres donnant c'est vrai tous les
matins à 9 heures voilà le redis c'est à
dire l'analyse on ne l'appelle pas
m'avancer saint martin
vous l'avez a généralement elle
m'appelle en numéro masqué je lui
réponds pas
on comprend que voilà l'audience est pas
ou feint 500 milles vous savez moi je
suis de manière très détendue dans la
journée le seul
la seule chose qui peut me stresser dans
une journée de la semaine dans l'année
c'est quand mon pote donc s'afficher mon
téléphone non à ce code doit signer mais
que sa fiche que ça sonne jacou de
stress s'est décrochée c'est un message
sert à rien la dorure rappelé l'urgence
oh merde vous allez qu'un jour j'ai pas
un truc il y avait un mec j'avais un
ancien dg et je le vaux restons et il
sait pas que je suis je suis dans le
même restaurant puis qu'est ce que je
fais je l'appelle et je le vois de loin
ils voient mon numéro
c'est comme ça il fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il appellera il a redoublé des votes et
qu'est ce que vous faites pour vous
déstresser
ah ben là c'est paradoxal mais j'ai un
album chez moi que tu as une photo de
vous
[Applaudissements]
si vous stress au quotidien avoue fabien
le cas quand on se lève de mauvais poil
touchera tous les matins alors on va on
peut dire oui parce que c'est un petit
scoop son petit scoop people 5 aussi un
manoeuvre au sénat l'ancien playboy non
non non non et reçoit vous voyez des
guillemets c'est très bien mais faut-il
y voilà il a pu voila voila se prêter au
jeu
[Rires]
il a pu se prêter au jeu dans l'est
aujourd'hui il est avec anne
ça fait 13 ans comme anne richard
l'actuel c'est la comédienne qui joue
dans boulevard du palais le génome
comédienne alors bravo c'est quoi taper
chaude mais elle en attend et donc vous
êtes avec elle non mais c'est vrai anne
richard si on peut trouver une photo
martin grâce à vous d'ailleurs sur
google c'est grâce à moi j'avais
présenté c'est moi qui vais présenter
avis aux célibataires voilà merci
sûrement pas si vous voulez que je vous
prends jamais à une masse salariale
s'est déjà présenté une ex oui bah oui
déjà je vous ai présenté hier je vous ai
présenté ses membres n'est qu'à 3 1 mais
c'est beau ce fut ma moyenne j'adore
toujours votre garde du corps il faut
arrêter avec lui de marié de son enfant
[Rires]
aux côtés de se sentir toujours en
sécurité cheveux rasés c'est bodyguard
bah oui je suis whitney houston 1,92
[Rires]
c'est qu'elle vient de dire je me bats
merci qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui
vous stresse bout alors moi c'est depuis
l'enfance ma mère m'a traumatisé avec le
l'horaire n'est jamais trop tard c'est
la qualité des gens oui et donc ne pas
traumatiser maintenant je suis faut
vraiment dû soit pile poil alors si on
réussit jamais jamais en retard voie et
que ce que vous faites pour déstresser
bas il ya plein il ya plein de technique
après il ya aussi la nourriture se
sentir bien dans son corps j'ai toujours
des plus manger un match dur risque eu
la viande des grisons aussi sympa si
vous adorez ça alors vous venez pas à
côté vous poser la question ouais c'est
vrai alors qu'est-ce qui est donc
voyager il ya deux formules très
importante pour moi mais qu'est-ce qui
vous stresse vous déjà ben moi c'est
anne se lève toujours de mauvaise humeur
tous les goûts tous les matins votre
neuf tous les matins et balayez humeur
pour toi et je le fais pour la remettre
de bonne humeur et qu'elle le voit c'est
un calais elle ouvre les yeux et merde
hélas hélas elle et non parce que je
suis celle des dix sept ans que son top
non parce que je suis copain avec ses ex
et donc et bien sûr on est très amis ont
fait noël ensemble et tout ça non badoer
vous le touchez pas les boules
[Applaudissements]
et de par la taille après deux trucs
déstresser 1
c'est quoi alors tu vas dire il faut se
mordre la langue l'extrémité de la
langue faites le fermer la bouche parce
que ça fait partir un jet de salive
ce qui fait que d'un seul coup non là
c'est très à la traîne de fabien qui est
très belle
et alors et croyez moi c'est un des
vrais trucs même c'est louis de funès
qui mêle de dessin journaux et parce que
lui la fédé courte tête jusqu'à 42 ans
ah ouais et alors les gens qui montent
sur scène qui ont trois qui sont
stressés à mort le manque de salif et
combat fouilles c'est ce qu'il a dit mme
banon mais alors il faut de ce qui
serait la prison puis on va voir driver
l'audio voir si ça marche vous faites
l'essai la gare au rendez-vous les
crudités la langue il ya un jet de
salive qui paraît comme c'est bon c'est
moi qui ai bien d'avoir la langue qui
colle au palais arrêts et la deuxième
chose pour déstresser le matin valérie
il faut prendre du recul pertuis nous
les cueillir s'arrête à l'usure du coi
du millepertuis dizaine de plants
du coup c'est une plante ça fait 2500
ans qu'on se soit glissé la nile pertuis
et pertinents le millepertuis cc comme
du thym sauvage c'est jaune quoi aller
sur un talus le matin besoin de paris
l'état tu veux être là tu perds tu nous
a dit roy moore d'adecco gfr mais non tu
as vu le mercure va pas ce que tu dis il
faut prendre et la tige du millepertuis
ça fait quatre ou cinq
petite astuce c'est quoi
non il faut il faut prendre du faux
mâché ou ou faire une infusion diffusion
de millepertuis ça c'est formidable
serre contre la mélancolie contre le
stress assez bien c'est formidable et
s'attend non je crois pas non merci en
tout cas très bonne année merci non mais
si je peux donner des trucs ça peut
aider des gens bien sûr mais là ça a
aidé des gens alors vous en fera un
autre jour qui vous a dit